today as Luke Perry's 50th birthday how
can I be bad boy Dylan 50 we did a
little digging through our ball for this
birthday flashback a year ago I was
shoveling asphalt in a year from now I
could be doing it again I think it keeps
a good perspective on things as long as
you remember that Luke went from working
on a road crew to one of the world's
biggest heartthrobs the only thing I'm
finding to call it a little less privacy
you know people know who you are you
just don't know who they are you don't
see them on TV any time you hear loud
noise like that it's a rush I mean an
explosion but when you know that it's
coming from people who really like your
work and they like the show that you're
on yeah that's the best feeling in the
world he was in his mid-20s playing a
high schooler and his James Dean like
image led to this 1992 Vanity Fair cover
he was now hanging with Hollywood
a-listers I learned tonight that uh Demi
Moore is a great dance
her dental skills are really you know
one of the best attributes a lot of
people don't get to see that gnome that
you are in 92 during a break from 90210
he started in the movie version of Buffy
the Vampire Slayer opposite Kristy
Swanson I'm in no hurry to have my name
above a title or to be the star of a
film I just hope that they that the
roles that I get are ones that will
fulfill me and allow me to get better in
93 he married Rachel Sharpe and had two
kids before divorcing and now he is
coming back in the spring for the CW
series Riverdale what happened
I've changed everything's changed based
on the Archie comics but with a dark
turn he's playing Artie's dad we were
with him at Comic Con this summer and
the 50 year old is now the vet on set
you're all very professional and and on
the pilot I was very impressed with how
they treated everybody and it showed up
on timing other stuff so it's gonna go
well for them
you